In this video I’m going to show you how
to make “Teddy Bear” toast. “Teddy Toast”
is fun and easy to make, and is a really cool
way to serve your hungry little cubs, a healthy snack.
For this “mealtime munchie”, you’ll
need to forage the kitchen for a banana, a
handful of blueberries, a piece of toast,
and a jar of peanut of butter.
Carve out a generous serving of peanut butter
and carefully smear it onto the toast, so
it leaves a nice creamy layer, just thick
and sticky enough, to hold some fruit.
Now cut the tip off a banana and carefully
slice three thin, circular pieces off the end,
and try to keep them all about the same
size if you can.
Two of the slices get pressed in at the top
of the toast, so they overhang the edges a little.
And the last piece goes right in the
middle.
Now at this point, our toast looks a little
more like a pig, than it does a teddy bear,
but all it takes to transform it is 3 little
blueberries.
Press two of the berries into the peanut butter
right, above the nose, and make sure the bottoms
are facing upward, to make beady little eyes.
Then simply stick the last berry right in
the middle, to finish it off.
Just like that, you’ve got a fun piece of
“Teddy Bear” Toast, ready to be captured
and enjoyed, by all your little “snack-time”
warriors.
So go make some with your kids.
They hardly take any time to put together,
and they’re a great way to get your youngsters
interested and excited, about eating a healthy
treat.
Well now you know a fun and easy way, to make
breakfast even better, by turning your toast, into “Teddy Bears”.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com